use a deacon what guests have to say
after the show okay we are back are the
boycotts against Israel justified I
dearly and painfully missed the time
where Israel had moral authority they
used to have some moral authority still
do they squandered it dramatically in
this period and I think they're
squandering it every day as we sit here
moral authority is what changes the
world and they used to have it and they
have much less of it now there's no
doubt you can't have it both ways run
you know yeah after the Second World War
everybody said how could the Israelis
just to be marched into the gas chambers
without fighting back well they got
tough and they fight back and they don't
like it when people fire rockets into
the terror that that's not the tough
Jews we've met the tough Jews with Moshe
Dayan that was 1968 and 73 what they've
done in this period though goes against
fundamental principles that frankly Jews
have embraced for a long time and that's
not in the character of Israel as it was
created there's no doubt about that
I think we got to get out of this period
here and you know hopefully some time
and very soon there's gonna be a
negotiated truce and then get back to
the bargaining table and settle this
question of a Palestinian state and the
way that Israel has to do that is to
recognize that it cannot continue
settlement development right right there
is otherwise there can't be another
state but let's have some let's have
some empathy also for the Israeli public
who are deeply skeptical about the
character of a future Palestinian state
because they live in a very dangerous
neighborhood I think it's easy for us
we're very far away from there to you
know kind of judge their behavior and
how they responded yeah people who have
made it no secret that they would like
this Israeli state to cease to exist
absolutely continue to protect the
Israeli neighborhood and I mean I think
you know this administration could not
make clearer that the United States is a
strong ally to Israel but there has to
be a negotiated agreement and it's got
to be with all Palestinians at the end
of the day there anything that doesn't
happen it doesn't make the neighborhood
any safer and
and they were talking about refugees
before I mean you know the Palestinians
could have had a deal on the table a
long time ago but they they would not
all those all those Arab countries with
all that empty land never wanted those
Palestinians those refugees they had
plenty of room for a lot of people but
no they wanted this problem and the
Palestinian leaders who want to make a
deal are incredibly vulnerable their
lives are in danger and that's the
that's the fundamental problem they are
the ones who I think the fundamental
problem is that people matter what
religion who think that the real party
is in the next world
just don't have as much motivation to
fix things in this one
that's Jason what is your opinion of
nuclear power and those who say it is
better for the environment
you know Fukushima taught us a lot about
the risks of nuclear and it was it
happened about a generation after people
started to forget about Chernobyl and
and that's the small value of that
horrible incident but I I say that
nuclear isn't safe some argue it should
be used as a transition energy source -
because it's low-carbon and I think that
we can get there by a bigger investment
in solar and wind
you don't need nuclear and you know when
you think about there's three words that
everybody knows Three Mile Island
Chernobyl Fukushima and each one got
worse virtually all of France's nuclear
power is a virtually there are seas
generated by nuclear power there are
many hundreds where it's been
tremendously safe there are new modular
designs there's pebble-bed reactors
there are new technologies that we've
stymied we prevented them from is true -
this makes a huge huge difference and
funnily it's baseload power wind and
solar this these are intermittent power
sources you need we have new storage
energy coming on and so we're nowhere
near the place where solar and wind are
gonna make a difference and what do you
think of the guy we were talking about
before from Kentucky who says that the
temperature on Mars
the same as Earth I think it's very
foolish and I think that fundamentally
when you actually talk about what's
actually going on you see that some
ideas and and and you know I have
enormous respect for the work that you
do and I value it tremendously but I
think that the idea that wind and solar
is gonna be solution the United States
economy is decarbonized faster than the
EU the EU had the emissions trading
scheme we had fracking I know you're not
a big fan but actually natural gas and
nuclear are the bridge to a cleaner
energy system and we need them and they
unfortunately fracking is releasing a
lot more methane than was thought it and
so it's not it's no it's burning more
lignite they're burning more of the
worst kind of coal because they're
actually shutting down nuclear power
plants that's what's gonna happen
if you don't allow for a kind of good to
you know you know a lot about this I
mean you're throwing around terms I
don't even they care about it yeah I
know you do so what do you say to people
on the Republican side like this guy in
Kentucky the the people who just just
seem to refuse to to want to live in the
world of facts you know I mean Bobby
Jindal said we have to stop being the
party of stupid after the last election
and of course then he got scared and ran
right back to stupid but how do you get
the Republican Party to not be stupid to
just at least be on the page of reality
well I disagree with with a lot of the
folks on the panel about this what I
believe is that the things that are
gonna lead to cheaper safer reliable
energy in the United States are also the
things that are gonna help the
environment and I think that when you're
trying to build a coalition because
ultimately we've got to build a larger
group of people people who are gonna
disagree on many things but you've got
to get a lot of people on the same page
and the way to do that is to emphasize
what are things that we all want and so
you know if you're looking at the price
of electricity it costs twice as much in
Germany as it does here and that makes a
big up you were talking up $130,000
before that makes a big difference to
people if you're about its help you
we're gonna deliver you cheaper and
cleaner energy that's something where
you can build a real coalition and
that's what you've got to talk about you
have to be willing to invest in those
technologies and the fact is I just
happened to go to work every day with a
whole bunch of people who don't believe
in making those investments who don't
believe in the science of climate change
who don't believe that it's important
for the United
to invest in the new technologies that
are going to change that actually does
believe in climate change Congress when
you have a Congress that doesn't and
that every single day even just this
week I mean we took votes saying we
don't want the Department of Defense
doing things that are going to respond
to its own climate assessment
it's a Cory Booker and Rand Paul making
so nice together this week
criminal justice what about criminal
justice reform well they did some sort
of forum together and then they were
like you know we can work together is
that the beginning of something
something like what like a Republican
and a Democrat actually not looking at
each other like they have horns growing
out of their head that is interesting I
think it has to begin though with people
with all of us on the same page agreeing
to the same basic facts I mean if you
can't agree to the same facts it makes
it really hard
is there a congressperson on the
Republican side you could buddy up with
like that like I could name a couple who
could you be friends with and work
together injured Hannah from New York oh
he's great no I'd never heard him
Republicans have been for energy
investment I mean arpa-e started under
the Bush administration MIT Romney ran
on more investment in energy I think
that there are plenty of conservatives
who's gonna be in trouble now that I
said it shouldn't be I mean that used to
be a good thing that used to be
something you know I think I mean I
think there are areas and member of
McCain and Hillary Clinton were like
buddies in the Senate for a while yeah
like I think the hard Republican right
is not having a good year I mean the
bottom line there's a lot of Republicans
that I talked to say we've got to take
them on because we can't win a national
election with the situation as it now
stands and I think that ambition well
that's we're living in a different
planet well no I don't think so
in fact it's emotion ambition is a good
motivator and they cannot win a national
election with the divisions they have
now
well the real motivator has to be what's
gonna make a difference in the lives of
the American people I agree with that
folks start focusing on that then time
we feel more massive villainous guests
or questions right after the show
at hbo.com or on Twitter
[Applause]